字幕: Takuma Suzuki
校正: Kazunori Akashi
私はロボットの研究者です
と言ってもなかなか目には見えない
小さな小さなロボットです
2018年にそんなロボットを
このステージでお話しさせていただきました
あれから４年が経ちました
今日はあのロボット達が
今どうしているのか
それをお伝えしたくて
このステージに戻ってきました
私たちのロボットは非常に小さなもの
ですけども 取柄が一つあります
群れを作ることができます
鳥や魚や蟻たちのように
整然とした群 これは
まさに自然が見せるスペクタクルです
群れることによって１羽あるいは１匹では
できなかったことが
次々とできるようになってきます
このように みんなで力を合わせて
自然界を生き抜いていく
こういった戦略が
私たちの研究の核にもなっています
水中を滑走している赤や緑の分子たちが
私たちが作り上げてきたロボットです
髪の毛の1000分の１ぐらいの
太さを持ったものです
ここに化学的な情報や
あるいは 光の信号を入力すると
それを受け取って
大きな群れを作り始めます
これは当時の学生であった彼女と共に
作り上げてきた そういったものでもあります
この成果はイギリスの科学雑誌
『Nature』という雑誌のオンライン版に
掲載されたものです
こういったロボットを作り上げる際には
３つの要素が必要になります
１つが環境をセンスするようなセンサー
そして２つ目がその情報処理するプロセッサ
３つ目がそのプロセッサからの指令を受けて
行動へと移すモーターになります
これが 我々のロボットの
モーター部分になります
生体の中では
いろいろな物質の運搬にかかわっている
タンパク質からなる分子機械になります
ATPという化学エネルギーを使って
駆動することができます
またプロセッサには遺伝子情報を
管理しているDNAが用いられています
そこに可視光や紫外光といったような
光を受けて構造変化する そういった化合物
これを組み込むことによって
センサー機能が備わっていきます
この図は 私たちのロボットを
模式的に表したものです
赤や緑の繊維状に見えるものが
これがDNAからなるプロセッサです
これを手のようにして使いながら
お互いコミュニケーションをとることで
群れを形成していく
これが基本的な原理になります
非常に小さなものですが 力を合わせれば
その可能性は無限大ではないだろうか
４年前にこのような言葉で
締めくくらせていただきました
この後 どの方向にこの可能性を
見出していったらよいのか
それは私たちがすべて鍵を握っています
まず最初に そもそもロボットには
何が期待されているのだろうか
このような問いかけから
次の一歩を踏み出していきました
これは 私が今座っているデスクの後ろにある
本棚から引っ張り出してきた
チェコの作家
カレル・チャペックの書籍です
1920年 今から100年ほど前に書かれた
戯曲になります
この中でロボットという言葉が
生まれてきました
ロボータ これはチェコ語で
労働というものを表す言葉です
この言葉の最後の１文字
これが取り払われると
我々が今使っている
ロボットという言葉に変わっていきます
この対比からもわかるように
ロボットには労働ということが
求められている
何か働くということが
求められていることがわかります
そこで我々も
私たちが作ってきたロボットに
何らかの仕事を課すことにしました
選んだのは荷物運びです
まずビジョンというのを
比較的容易に描くことができる
それから労働というものを目で確認する
ことができるというのが その理由になります
我々の頭の中にイメージされていたのは
「蟻」による餌運びのような情景です
蟻は周囲を探索し
餌らしきものを見つける
そしてそれが餌であることを確認すると
拾い上げて巣まで送り届ける
非常に簡単そうですよね
学生と共に まずはどんな物質を
運ばせたらいいのか これを探しに行きました
そして我々はマイクロプラスチック
のようなものを選びました
まず最初に１マイクロメートルぐらいの
プラスチック製のビーズを用意して
先程のロボットの中に投げ入れてみます
緑色に見えているのが
投げ入れたビーズの球になります
もちろん最初から
うまくいくわけはありません
そばを通りはするものの
通り過ぎてしまいます
そこで次にもう少し工夫をすることにしました
この玉が拾うべきものである
ということを認識させるために
その玉の表面に少し細工をします
DNAを貼り付けてみました
するとどうでしょうか　少しずつ球が転がり
始めるということがわかってきました
しかしこの動画を見るように
ロボットは球を拾い上げはするものの
すぐに落としてしまいます
これはビーズの軌跡を追ったものになります
この図からもビーズは遠くまで運べない
ということがわかります
ここで研究の核にもなっている
「力を合わせて何かを成し遂げていく」
この基本コンセプトに立ち戻っていきました
これは蟻の社会でも一緒です
大きな餌を運ぶ
こういった場合には仲間を呼んで
協力しながら この作業を完結させる
ここでは今 ３匹の蟻が
描かれているかと思います
我々はそこでまず 大きな大きな群れを
作らせることにしました　このような感じです
そして この矢印に注目していただくと
このビーズがその群れによって
のみ込まれていく
こういった様子を捉えることができました
同じように軌跡をとってみます
先ほどとは違うように見えます
比較をすると歴然でした
そこで次に単位時間あたりに
どれぐらいの距離を運んでいるのか
すなわち 輸送効率
これを評価してみることにしました
そうすると驚くべきことに５倍以上の差が
あるということがわかりました
私 研究という仕事にこれまで20年近く
携わってまいりましたけれども
この結果というのはその中でも
最も興奮させられるものでもありました
また 輸送の効率だけではなく
運ぶことのできるビーズのサイズにも大きな
違いが生まれてくるということがわかりました
ここでは１マイクロから30マイクロといった
サイズのビーズを投げ入れたものになります
単独で輸送する場合には１マイクロメートルの
ビーズこれが限界であったのに対して
群れで輸送する場合には 20マイクロ
といったような大きなビーズであっても
力強く運んでくれるということがわかりました
このように
蟻をイメージしながら「探索」
「積込」そして「搬送」というところまでは
比較的順調に研究を
進めてくることができました
しかしこの最後の「配達」というところには
かなり頭を悩ませていました
というのも運ぶためにはビーズをしっかりと
つかんでいなければならない
それを運ぶ場合には
すっと手を緩める必要があると
まったく相反する特性というのが
求められています
また散らばっているビーズを
どのようにしてかき集めてくればよいのか
ただ単にＡ地点からＢ地点にレールを引いて
物を運ばせるというわけにはいきませんでした
私 テストになると全くからっきし
だったんですけれども
歴史に関しては大変興味がありました
特にその時代が
どのようにして発展していったのか
あるいは その時の支配者が
どのようにして地域を覇権していったのか
そのサクセスストーリーにはいつも
ワクワクさせられていました
このような課題で頭を悩ましている際に
ふと浮かんだのが
２つの帝国のインフラ戦略でした
ローマでは舗装道というものを
都市間を直線的に結んで
その上を重戦車を走らせて
物資や人員を送り届ける
一方で モンゴル帝国では舗装道の
ようなものは全く持たず
草原を縦横無尽に馬車で駆け回る
ローマ帝国では効率のようなものを
モンゴル帝国では自由度
こういったものを求めたんだと思います
そこで私たちもレールを作るのではなく
モンゴル帝国型の戦略でこの物資輸送を
完結させようというふうに考えました
ではどのようにして
ビーズをあるところに送り届けるのか
私たちのロボットは
光に対する感受性があります
これをうまく利用すれば
光の当たった箇所にのみ
ビーズを届けることができるんじゃないか
こういうふうに考えました
これはその時の発想 イメージになります
そこで次に行ったのが ある箇所にのみ
紫外光 これを当てて
実際に群がばらけるかどうかを評価しました
紫色に囲まれている領域
ここに紫外光が当たっています
そこに群れが入ってくるとどうでしょうか
ばらけていく様子が
見て取れるのではないかと思います
またこれは私だけかもしれませんが
この動画を見ていると
ロボットであるにもかかわらず
何か生命体のような雰囲気を
感じてしまいます
今 どんどんばらけていきます
このようにしてばらけさせることが
できるということがわかってきたので
次いよいよこの中にビーズを入れていきます
もうすでに周囲を駆け回ってきたのか
多くのビーズを抱えた
ロボットたちが見られます
それが紫外光の当たった領域に
入ってこようとしています
すると群れがばらけると同時に そこに
ビーズを置いているということがわかりました
私たちの発想が間違っていなかったと
いうことが証明された瞬間でもあります
この成果に関しては アメリカの科学雑誌
『Science Robotics』というところに
つい最近掲載されたものです
もちろんこれは 論文の中では
一切触れられておりませんが
このプロセスに関しては
我々はほとんどの時間を
この４年間費やしてきました
大変苦労したポイントでもあります
また この動画から恐らくスケールが
全然伝わらないかと思いますが
今 この空間というのが大体
100マイクロメートルから
100マイクロメートルという
四角い領域になっています
これは我々の髪の毛１本の断面積に
相当するようなものです
非常に小さな空間にビーズを
置いていってくれると
私たちとしても非常に驚きな
結果ではありました
これは ある単位面積あたりに
どれぐらいのビーズの密度が変化するのか
ということを評価したものです
データからも紫外光が当たった領域のみ
ビーズが集まっているということが
サポートされたものでもあります
さて ４年前に誕生した私たちの
小さな小さなロボット
群れることしかできませんでしたが
ようやくここまでできるようになってきました
蟻の餌運び こういったものを
イメージしたように
ビジョンさえ描くことができれば
多少思っているものとは
異なっているかもしれませんが
それなりの結果が得られてくる
そういうふうに思います
進むべき方向は
我々が自由に選ぶことができる
だから研究はすごく面白い
そしてこれからもその研究を
追い求めていきたいと思います
どうもありがとうございます